okay so I was talking in the lowest
section of Beltre you know going to New
Zealand and finding out meeting sadhus
NZ when I grabbed him and he said I was
too strong the men of Pelham cuerpos
putting into him I don't know if I've
ever put more into anybody the next
thing I was looking up from the floor
and I could be jumped out I remember
hands in the ready position and he
wasn't there in front of me he throw me
along well I thought I'd come up in
front of him I was completely the
opposite why I didn't feel the flow
I didn't even know that I've been thrown
although member was a reaction to
quickly gathered myself and get back up
he done this year after year after year
and even till the day passed from this
earth he always amazed me
he just got smooth my Kannamma caught
his power was always far more greater
than what you would consider a human
being could have but never had never
brutal just like a marshmallow when you
grabbed him well the power would be so
great to throw you through the air and
all you knew was the coming up and
back to attack him again this is the
Colin I knew that failed my master and I
knew that I wanted to learn his Aikido
because the Aikido had and took with me
to New Zealand I thought I was one of
the best in the country at the time for
my level it was like a child playing the
elephant compared to what the people
that he brought with him from a warmer
the skills they had they won't follow
better than made I was the second down
black belt and he's first to brown belts
were far more knowledgeable than me more
polished than me so made me realize that
I've been living a dream and I needed to
know what they knew for the next 10
years it took me that long to wash away
the Aikido had in my body and to learn
from his techniques it I know it sounds
like I might be knocking the aikikai I
couldn't do there fast continuous
training I would didn't have the stamina
at any point in my career yes I could
have it done I used to run five miles
every day I tried to get super fit and I
could have trained at that pace if I'd
wanted to by chosen one the ruing Aikido
because to me the power and the
guarantee that you know it would work in
a situation was far greater than just
enjoying myself training with other
people and having the del would it
really work if I needed it if you learn
in one with techniques you learn can
wooden sword and gel wooden staff as
well as body techniques
why do you learn them you learn them for
body alignment when you when you're
training with another person and as you
get better you get faster more accurate
when you hear the cane whistle past your
ear because it was so close but you know
that if it hit you you may not be here
today that allows you to overcome panic
so it builds up as you slowly with a
part of trainer weapons the closer it
gets and the nearer gets the hitting you
you start off slowly but then it builds
panic you first understand to understand
panic once you get used to that you
forget it and you can enjoy a even more
but then you become even better yourself
higher ranked you become trapped you
become able to train with all the higher
ranks it gets faster it gets as close as
you can to reality then fear you reach
the point of fear and fear is when your
whole body fears the thought of the
other person hitting you because they're
attacking you 100% for real they don't
have to be attacking you with aggression
or anger further behind the person will
but they do if they attack you 100% but
with a cat or movement with a weapon and
you've taste a fear
then you have to go to the next level
while I don't go to the next level was I
trained with live will live blade swords
one was my friends who was a fifteenth
century and one that I had what was the
17th century so they would true samurai
swords we should get prepare for
demonstrations but we wanted it as well
as could be and when you hear that
whistle as the same past your ears past
your head and you realize how close you
come you've overcome fear and you've put
you've accepted death it's very odd
thing to say but you've accepted death
nobody wants to die but you've accepted
that that can happen because that's how
fast and that's how close it becomes if
you don't have a real good Aikido
technical ability in the body arts the
weapons and all those combined inner
senses art it will fail you and if it
fails you you'll be the hospital you
will die you will not feel complain cite
yourself as a person or more than any oh
that's that's my that's my ladies are
I've always said I don't want a copy of
the Mona Lisa painting I would want the
original don't I can afford it
ok so I hope you've enjoyed that piece I
will keep talking about the technical
side the body techniques than that as we
go okay thank you and again please leave
your thoughts below